I hate to be the one to break it to the Billy's of the world
but your own mother may very well be one of these murderers herself
we know that 25% of women have an abortion in their lifetime
and of that 25% six out of ten are already mothers
one of the main reasons people report wanting to have an abortion
is that they can be a better parent to the kids they already have
all of us have benefited from abortion
whether it is that your mother was able to be a better parent to you
whether it was that she had an abortion before you
so that she could have healthy planned pregnancy later
which was you find yourself saying well
I don't know any women who have had an abortion
the women around me don't do that
yes they do
they are just well aware of the fact that you are not a safe person to tell
it is 25% of the women around you
it is your mother's friends
your sisters it is rich women
poor women religious women
women who are not religious
women from all different cultures and backgrounds
so as much as I hate your energy
I'm glad that you have also benefited from abortion